LIED ABOUT IN THE GUN
APPLICATION THROWN IN A
DUMPSTER.
WE'LL FOLLOW CLOSELY.
AND I VIOLENT IS EXPLODING IN
CHICAGO AS MANY BIG BLUE
STATES AND CITIES, MURDERS GO T.
JOHN WALSH WILL JOIN US FOR AN
INVESTIGATION TONIGHT AND
PRINCE HARRY, BRITAIN'S MOST
ENTITLED, MOST INSUFFERABLE
CELEBRITY ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
HAS NOW CHOSEN TO PRESIDE
FULL-TIME IN THE U.S.
HE WANTS A QUIET LIFE OUT OF THE
PUBLIC EYE BUT HE JUST ANNOUNCED
OUR COUNTRY DURING A SPEECH AT
THE UNITED NATIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PIERS MORGAN
WHERE THE GOOD PRINCE IS LIVING
IN A COUNTRY THAT BRINGS THEM SO
MUCH SHAME.
BY THE WAY HE WILL SEND THEM
RIGHT BACK HOME TO YOU WHEN HE
WILL JOIN US IN A BIT.
FIRST TONIGHT, THE SKY IS
FALLING YET AGAIN.
THE EARTH'S IMMINENT DESTRUCTION
IS NOW BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THEY REALLY MEAN IT THIS TIME.
NATURALLY THE ONLY WAY TO SAVE
HUMANITY'S TO GIVE THEM MORE
POWER.
SO TODAY YOUR PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN BOARDED AIR FORCE ONE
AND FOR A SHORT HIGH CARBON
FOOTPRINT FLIGHT TO
MASSACHUSETTS AND THEN WENT FOR
A RIDE IN A GIANT FLEET OF GAS
GUZZLING SUVs, SPECIFICALLY
SHIPPED FROM WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND THEN TRAVELED TO A DESK
COVERED A LOT OF FILLED WITH THE
DIESEL POWERED EXCAVATORS WHERE
THEY PLAN TO MANUFACTURE
UNDERWATER CABLES FOR WIND
TURBINES AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE.
AS SOMEONE ON TWITTER PUT IT,
NOTHING SCREAMS REASSURANCE LIKE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SPEAKING LIVE FROM
AN ABANDONED LOT NEXT TO A STRIP
CLUB NEAR THE AIRPORT.
BIDEN WAS THERE TO TOUT
AMERICA'S GREAT TRANSITION TO
CLEAN ENERGY.
TRANSITION, KEYWORD, AND PREVIEW
HIS BIG UPCOMING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
JOE BASTARDI WILL JOIN US ON
THIS IN A BIT BUT HE EXTERNALLY
TOLD EVERYONE THAT HE HAS CANCER
WHICH WE DIDN'T KNOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> A LITTLE SCHOOL I WENT TO,
HOLY ROSARY GRADE SCHOOL AND
BECAUSE IT WAS A FOUR LANE
HIGHWAY THAT WAS ACCESSIBLE,
MY MOTHER DROVE US RATHER THAN
US BE ABLE TO WALK AND GUESS
WHAT, THE FIRST FROST, YOU KNEW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING, YOU HAD TO
PUT ON YOUR WINDSHIELD WIPERS TO
GET LITERALLY THE OIL SLICK OFF
THE WINDOW.
THAT IS WHY I AM SO DAMN MANY
OTHER PEOPLE I GREW UP WITH HAVE
CANCER.
>> Sean: TURNS OUT JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T HAVE CANCER.
THE WORST WALK BACK PERHAPS
EVER.
JOE WAS PERHAPS REFERRING TO THE
REMOVAL OF A NONMELANOMA,
NONLIFE-THREATENING SPOT ON HIS
SKIN WHICH ACCORDING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN WAS
CAUSED BY 78 YEARS IN THE SUN,
NOT WHEEL AS HE CLAIMS FALLING
FROM THE SKY IN DELAWARE.
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT,
NOBODY KNOWS.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN FORCED TO
ISSUE AN EMBARRASSING CORRECTION
FOLLOWING A SPEECH BY JOE BIDEN.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER A YEAR AGO
THEY WALKED BACK HIS CLAIM THAT
THE LAST FIVE FED SHARES, TWO OF
WHICH ARE DEAD, SUPPORT HIS
SPENDING PLANS.
LAST OCTOBER, THEY WALKED BACK
HIS BOW TO CALL UP THE
NATIONAL GUARD, AND IN JANUARY
THEY HAD TO WALK BACK HIS PLEDGE
TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY IF
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVASION
INTO -- HIS REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA AND HIS FAILED TO RESPOND
IN KIND TO A CHEMICAL WEAPONS
INTACT.
IN MAY THEY HAD TO WALK BACK HIS
PLEDGE TO GO TO WAR WITH CHINA
OVER TAIWAN AND IN JULY THE
WHITE HOUSE PRETENDED THAT JOE
MEANT TO READ THE SPEAKING
QUEUES ON THE TELEPROMPTER,
REPEAT THE LINE WHICH AS YOU
KNOW HAS NOW GONE VIRAL, KIND
OF LIKE "LET'S GO BRANDON AND WE
COULD GO ON AND ON.
BUT LET'S GET ON TO THE LOOMING
APOCALYPSE NOW, OR AS MAYOR PETE
PUT IT, WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
OUR DAYS ARE NUMBERED, THE END
IS NEAR.
IF THE END IS NEAR LET'S JUST
THROW ONE HELL OF A BIG PARTY ON
THE WAY OUT, THAT'S MY IDEA.
>> NOBODY THINKS YOU CAN MAKE
THIS CHANGE OVERNIGHT BUT THERE
IS A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CLIMATE, WE
ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
THE SCIENCE IS UNAMBIGUOUS IN
TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF THREAT
COME IN TERMS OF THE LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS THAT AMERICA AND THE
WORLD STAND TO LOSE IF WE DON'T
ACCELERATE OUR ACTION.
>> Sean: THIS IS OF COURSE A
PRETENSE FOR THEIR GIANT
SOCIALIST POWER GRAB.
THAT IS WHAT GREEN NEW DEALISM
IS ALL ABOUT.
YOU GIVE UP YOUR RATES FOR EMPTY
PROMISES, YOU EMPTY OUT YOUR
WALLETS FOR LESS FREEDOM IN
EXCHANGE FOR WHAT THEY SAY IS
GOVERNMENT PAID HOUSING
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT SALARY,
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT JOB,
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT
HEALTH CARE, GUARANTEED
GOVERNMENT HEALTHY FOOD,
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT PAID
VACATION, GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT
PAID FOR CLEANER, GREENER
PLANET.
YOU MIGHT HAVE NOTICED DEMOCRATS
ARE CALLING THIS A TRANSITION.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
TRANSITION, WE ARE
TRANSITIONING, TRANSITIONING,
TRANSITIONING.
WHAT ARE WE TRANSITIONING TO?
WHAT IS THE ALTERNATIVE TO OIL
GAS AND COAL?
OKAY, RENEWABLES.
WHAT RENEWABLES?
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF 15 YEARS AGO AMERICA
GENERATED HALF OF ITS
ELECTRICITY FROM COAL-FIRED
PLANTS.
TODAY THAT IS DOWN TO 20%
BECAUSE THERE IS A BIG
TRANSITION HAPPENING.
>> THIS IS WHAT A TRANSITION
LOOKS LIKE, THIS IS EXACTLY THE
CHALLENGE WE ARE LIVING THROUGH.
>> TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED TO GROW THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY BUT NOT TO ENDANGER THE
CLIMATE WORK WE ARE TRYING TO DO
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE IN A BETTER
FOOTING TO ACCELERATE THE
TRANSITION THE TRANSITION.
>> WE ALL HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE --
>> THIS CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION
COULD BE THE PEACE PROJECT OF
OUR TIME.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE GAS
CRISIS, WE ARE GOING THROUGH AN
INCREDIBLE TRANSITION THAT IS
TAKING PLACE THAT GOD WILLING,
WHEN IT'S OVER WE WILL BE
STRONGER AND THE WORLD WILL BE
STRONGER.
>> Sean: THE ONLY WAY TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE TO ENERGY
DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIA, IRAN,
SAUDI ARABIA, OPEC AND
VENEZUELA, COUNTRIES THAT HATE
OUR GUTS.
HE WANTS TO MAKE THEM RICH AGAIN
ENDOSPORE AGAIN AND IS DEPENDENT
AGAIN AND COMPROMISE ON NATIONAL
SECURITY IN THE MEANTIME.
THIS SO-CALLED TRANSITION, DID
YOU GET THE WORD OF THE DAY?
TRANSITION WILL NOT MAKE LIFE
BETTER ON THE PLANET, IT WILL
MAKE THE PLANET ANY CLEANER IN
EFFECT FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE, AT LEAST THE NEXT COUPLE
DECADES, IS LOGISTICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
TRANSITION TO THEIR RENEWABLE
SOURCES OF ENERGY.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT UP TO
SPEED TO BEGIN WITH.
YESTERDAY THE GENIE IS
MAYOR PETE TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARIAT KNOWN FOR FILLING
POTHOLES IN SOUTH BEND, INDIANA,
SAID HE LIKED THE PAIN IT IS
CAUSING YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THE PAIN IT'S CAUSING IS GOOD.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE MORE PAIN WE ARE
ALL EXPANSIVE AND THE HIGH
PRICE OF GAS THE MORE BENEFIT TS
FOR THOSE WHO CAN ACCESS
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
>> Sean: THE MORE PAIN, THE
MORE BENEFIT.
WHILE THAT GENIUS MAYOR PETE IS
APPLAUDING YOUR PAIN, JOE BIDEN
CONTINUES TO RESTRICT OUR
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION OF OIL AND
GAS, FEELING THE VOID OF HEAVY
POLLUTERS IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
SOUTH AMERICA AND ANYWHERE ELSE
BUT HERE.
OF COURSE THIS GREAT TRANSITION
IS NOT ABOUT SAVING THE PLANET.
IF THE EARTH IS IN SUCH DANGER,
WHY DOESN'T THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GIVE UP THEIR
MASSIVE FLEET?
THEY HAVE 924 JETS OR
HELICOPTERS.
OF THAT CAUSES THE TAX PAYER
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
DO YOU PAY FOR THE JET FUEL, YOU
PAY FOR THE BIG FAT CARBON
FOOTPRINT.
IN REALITY IT IS NOT ABOUT THE
PLANET.
INSTEAD IT IS ALL BACKED OR
SOCIALISM.
DEMOCRATS IN THEORY RULE IN
PERPETUITY.
ONE BIG PROBLEM AS IT STANDS
NOW, ALMOST NO ONE SUPPORTS
JOE BIDEN OR HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, BUT MORE PAIN IS
BETTER FOR THEIR AGENDA.
NOW THEY'RE HISTORICALLY
UNPOPULAR BRENDA QUINNIPIAC POLL
OUT TODAY, BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING DROPPED TO ANOTHER LOW, S
IT IS EVEN LOWER, 23% AND
ACCORDING TO THE SAME POLL'S
APPROVAL AMONG
HISPANIC AMERICANS IS EVEN
LOWER, 19%.
NOW MAJORITY OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS PULLED, THEY
DON'T WANT BIDEN TO RUN FOR A
SECOND TERM.
KEEP